[Music]
hello
and welcome to our debate which is the
end of the whitewash
we celebrate diversity and in the arts
many support
colorblind casting from the film david
copperfield to the musical hamilton
stories are cast to reflect the
diversity of our culture
but far from being progressive critics
argue that the racist
victorian society of dickens novels
and the colonial history of america are
thereby papered over
and obscured should we applaud the
overcoming of historical accuracy
in favor of racially blind
representation
and equal opportunities for actors
irrespective of race
or is colour blindness a liberal mistake
a dangerous denial of racial identity
and the long history of white supremacy
and we have a very illustrious panel to
discuss this subject
aja ander is a renowned film television
radio and stage actor as well as a
director and writer
she's recently played casca in the
bridges julius caesar
and she's also directed and starred as
the eponymous
king in richard ii a critically
acclaimed production
as was julius caesar we also have
kain day andrews who's a professor of
black studies
at birmingham city university and has
developed
europe's very first black studies
undergraduate degree
his latest book is back to black
retelling black radicalism for the 21st
century
and we also have will self who is an
award-winning writer political
commentator
and broadcaster in 2012
his novel umbrella was shortlisted for
the man booker prize for fiction and in
the same year he was appointed professor
of contemporary thought
at brunel university and his latest book
will is an experimental work of memoir
so to begin with our opening question
which i'll pose to ajar ando first
and the question is is race relevant
to historical stories and portrayals
after three minutes thank you my
dyspraxic child's pediatric occupational
therapist
described the effort exactly every day
on the dyspraxia
person like this so the average person
walks along the street to the
box posts a letter walks away
the person with my child's level of
dyspraxia walks up a steep hill
watching the ground so they don't turn
an ankle on root judges the angle of the
post box mouth to the angle of the
letter insertion post a letter
then walks cautiously back down that
steep hill
and repeat that same level of extra
effort
every day in this country
as in any majority ethnically european
country especially one that has
colonial adventurism in its dna
in such a country if you are a child of
colour
the effort of your daily life is like
that of the dyspraxic child
the difficulty for that child of color
here encountered
is not one of inherited physical
disability but the disability of
projected
social prejudice and assumption so the
weight of that projected social
prejudice
mitigates daily against our confidence
and presses on us a relentless internal
conversation
questioning our gifts our intuition our
responses it's debilitating
and it demands huge reserves of
concentration self-reflection
and discernment to hold one's ground
i don't want to be here having this
conversation i have bok choy and
broccoli outside that needs planting
but for all the young me the young
hyundais the young wills the young
sineads
the young joanna's i want to share
through my work the richness of who we
are that we are all of equal value
and work worthy of equal interest simply
because we exist
and that's enough so to the point the
original
question should we applaud the
overcoming of historical accuracy in
favor of racially blind representation
and ignore race as a relevant
characteristic in all circumstances
or is color blindness a liberal mistake
a dangerous denial
of racial identity in a long history of
white supremacy
so i have to say depositing of this
question tonight speaks to whether the
event organizes
ignorance or more likely to their desire
to provoke
but indeed it speaks also to our
national ignorance as a country
of our history and the place of a range
of heritages and contributions within it
but kyende can speak with more authority
on that
i've had 30 years of my children in
education one of them is a teacher my
mother was also a history teacher
and i don't know about you but over
those 30 years it seemed to me that my
kids mainly learned about the tudors
and the nazis and then not even about
the huge trading and multicultural
life of the tudors nor the military
service and sacrifice of the colonial
armed forces in all the wars
or the murder in concentration camps
across
europe under the nazis of europe's
existing populations of color
without a proper assessment of our
history
no wonder we are confused about who we
are in this a historical fantasyland
there is always a conversation to be had
about the man-made barriers of class
and race and gender and ability
disability and sexuality and income and
caste
but that conversation is always also
about the integration
and contribution of that shared humanity
the reality of the lives lived takes
take nelson's column
the freeze at its base nelson is being
held by a black sailor because a fifth
of the british navy at that time
approximately was black so to that
question
let's overcome historical inaccuracy in
favor of racially
accurate representation and gender and
class and sexuality etc
so that's a lot of dramas we'd have to
ditch even really contemporary stuff
have another go with lots of historical
dramas war movies
the first british troops sent into ipr
in 1916
to road test the effects of mustard gas
on the human lung
for example with the british indian
regiments who died in their tens of
thousands for king and country queen
charlotte
wife to george iii not helen mirren i'm
afraid mixed race
daughter of alfonso the third of
portugal and his african mistress
who of course has no name it's in
contemporary documents of the time so
meghan markle late to that party i'm
afraid i've just filmed a netflix series
with
a mixed race queen charlotte in which i
play a director duchess
bridgeton coming soon so what we're
talking about here is reintegrating our
history
i want to turn now to kyende andrews for
the same question
um which is is race relevant to
historical stories and portrayals
uh yes so race is always relevant and
the color blindness is always a bad idea
and i give you lots of examples and
where it's a bad idea but generally
to ignore race and to ignore color is to
uh just give space to whiteness that's
what we're really talking about
because this is the idea that when we
talk about race you're talking about
people of color
but white people have race and in fact
white people's race has probably been
the most important because it is shaped
history culture etc etc so when you say
color blindness we're really saying
let's um ignore the critique of white
and in the in the tvs and in the art
production you can see this really
really really clearly
and it's more than just changing people
who are in
the cast it's actually about the stories
that we tell so the stories that we're
telling are
are the stories that we are comfortable
with as a society
they are the lady was saying it's the
it's the war movies
um i mean i can't i genuinely think
that's all we watched in school
was war movies and movies about the
royal family right it's these period
pieces
where we go back and we romanticize and
think about history in this way
one of the only things we really talk
about critically in in culture
and feel comfortable in in britain is
class so there's all these different
issues about class and isn't it great
we've overcome class inequality et
cetera et cetera so there's this
there's this comfort in this support
narrative
of the society that we're in there's a
more dangerous version of this as well
which is where actually we imagine that
those stories are the real story
so for example all these war movies how
many black and brown people do you see
in them
um as eduardo was saying the war was the
world war these were empires fighting
each other
and millions by millions by millions of
caribbean african
asians fought in all these wars and yet
aren't represented in those stories
uh the same when we think about period
pieces so if you go back to the bronties
the various bronte shows are always done
always be shown on tv
and what you always see is always
homogeneous homogeneous whiteness the
aristocracy
this is a time when there was slavery
this is a time when there was
colonialism we never hear any of those
stories are given this delusional
fantasy version
of reality and what that does is it
really does distort how we understand
the present world
we don't generally understand what it
means to be british
i don't have to prove there are black
people in britain 100 years 200 years
ago
to prove that i'm british my parents and
my grandparents in the caribbean
were born in britain it was a colony of
britain only in the caribbean
because we're taking in chains from
africa by britain so we've always been
here we've always contributed but we
have a cultural space which completely
not really ignores it
so the question here isn't well it's
it's better to replace blackface
characters with black actors
that doesn't hardly makes blackface
performances okay
and this unfortunately is a good analogy
because this is largely our cultural
production
it is these narrow relatively racist
highly used
um that don't get to grips with the real
history of british and just replacing
those
people could never possibly deal with
the problem so it's actually about
changing the stories that we tell
thanks very much kain day and now i'll
move to will self with the same
question is race relevant to historical
stories and portrayals thank you will
well i mean it certainly is today and
it's a very contentious issue and
anybody who didn't
see that it was contentious would be in
some weird kind of denial
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai dot tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas